>> Sandra: WISCONSIN’S
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY ELECTION
HAPPENING TODAY.
LAST NIGHT, THE STATE
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNING A
LAST-MINUTE EXECUTIVE ORDER BY
THE GOVERNOR TO SUSPEND IN
PERSON VOTING UNTIL JUNE.
MIKE TOBIN’S LIFE WITH THE
LATEST ON ALL OF THAT.
>> WISCONSIN VOTERS WHO CHOOSE
TO ARE GOING TO THE POLLS TODAY
AFTER 18 CHAOTIC HOURS AND HIGH
COURT DECISIONS THAT HANDED TO
FEEDS TO THE DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR.
THE STATE SUPREME COURT WHICH IS
CONTROLLED BY REPUBLICANS TOLD
HIM HE MAY NOT DELAY THE
ELECTION UNTIL JUNE AND THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT SAID THE ABSENTEE
BALLOTS MUST BE POSTMARKED
TODAY.
THE CHALLENGE WAS BROUGHT BY
REPUBLICAN STATE LAWMAKERS AND
THAT BROUGHT THE IRE OF HIM WHO
WROTE "THOUSANDS WILL WAKE UP
AND HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE AND STAYING
HEALTHY AND SAFE.
REPUBLICANS IN WISCONSIN WHO
CONTROL THE LEGISLATURE PUSHED
BACK AGAINST THE DELAY AND HIS
EFFORTS AT A MAILING VOTE.
THEY SAID HE BROUGHT THE CHANGES
TOO LATE.
>> THEY SHOULD HAVE DEALT WITH
THIS WEEKS AGO.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE GOVERNOR
HIMSELF WAS SAYING SHOULD BE AN
ELECTION IN TWO WEEKS AGO OR
LESS THAN TWO WEEKS AGO, HE SAID
HE COULDN’T DO ANYTHING AND THEN
JUST DAYS AGO, HE CALLED FOR A
SPECIAL SESSION AND TODAY HE
SWITCHED YET AGAIN SAYING
THEY’RE GOING TO POSTPONE IT.
>> TIM CARPENTER SAID WISCONSIN
IS THE ONLY STATE STUPID ENOUGH
TO HAVE AN ELECTION APRIL 7TH.
ROUGHLY 1.3 MILLION ABSENTEE
BALLOTS HAVE BEEN REQUESTED.
AT THE ELECTION COMMISSION
PREDICTS CLICKS WILL BE
OVERWHELMED.
MANY ARE COMPLAINING THEY HAVE
NOT RECEIVED THEIR ABSENTEE
BALLOTS IN THE MAIL YET.
MILWAUKEE USUALLY HAS 100
POLLING STATIONS OPEN DUE TO
SHORTAGES OF VOLUNTEERS.
FIVE ARE OPERATING.
THE NATIONAL GUARD HAS BEEN
ACTIVATED AND GUARDS MEN AND
WOMEN HAVE BEEN TRAINED TO BE
VOLUNTEERS AT POLLING LOCATIONS.
THEY WILL WEAR PLAIN CLOTHES AND
WORK IN THE COUNTIES WHERE THEY